You know, usually when we talk about medical diagnosis, there's this, um, this
expectation of absolute precision.
Right.
Like engineering or something.
Yeah, exactly.
Like you break your arm, the X-ray shows that jagged white line and the
doctor just points at it and says, you know, there it is.
It's comforting.
I mean, we like things to be visible, to be binary.
It's either broken or it's not broken.
Right.
But then you step into the world of neurodevelopment.
Like the way the human brain wires itself during childhood, and suddenly
that X-ray machine is just, well, it's utterly useless.
We're looking at a diagnostic landscape that is incredibly murky.
Oh, absolutely.
I mean, medical students spend hours, sometimes days, just memorizing
these exact boundaries for their board exams.
But if you look past the clinical checklist, what we're really talking
about is trying to categorize human behavior and you know, human behavior
is messy, which is exactly why we're exploring this today.
Our goal for this deep dive is to figure out how modern psychology
actually draws the lines between these overlapping conditions.
Yeah, it's so important.
Because whether you're, I don't know, trying to understand a child's
struggles or making sense of your own brain, or just fascinated by
how we define normal, understanding these specific boundary lines
gives you a much clearer lens.
It really does.
It helps you see where a personality quirk ends and a fundamental
neurological baseline begins.
And that concept of a neurological baseline, that is the
perfect starting point for us.
The unifying thread of every condition we're exploring today is
that they are neurodevelopmental.
Right.
Meaning they start early.
Exactly.
They begin in childhood, you know, while the brain is still
actively laying down its primary neural pathways.
So let's start with a condition that is heavily discussed in our
culture right now, but often completely misunderstood regarding
how it's actually diagnosed, autism spectrum disorder.
A really classic example of these boundaries.
Yeah.
To get this diagnosis, modern clinical criteria demand two
mandatory core features.
First, there have to be persistent deficits in social
communication and interaction.
And second, there must be restricted, repetitive patterns
of behavior, interests, or activities.
And, you know, the clinical phrasing can sound a bit cold,
but it's crucial to understand the mechanism here.
We aren't just talking about someone who is introverted.
No, not at all.
The social communication piece means the brain genuinely struggles
to automatically process the unspoken fluid dynamics of human
interaction, like reading the room, understanding sarcasm, or
just the natural back and forth of a conversation.
And what about that second piece, the restricted,
repetitive behaviors?
Well, that's often the brain's coping mechanism.
Oh, really?
Yeah.
Think about it.
If the social world feels chaotic and unpredictable and
just overwhelming to process, the brain craves order.
That makes sense.
So it creates predictability through repetitive movements or
rigid adherence to routines, or even intense, highly focused
interest in a specific topic.
It's basically a way to anchor an overwhelmed sensory system.
That makes so much sense when you frame it as an anchor.
But here's where the diagnostic boundaries get tricky based
on what we're looking at.
You need both.
It's a mandatory pairing.
Yes, absolutely.
I imagine it like a two key verification system on a nuclear submarine.
That's a great way to put it.
You need the social communication key.
Yeah.
And you need the repetitive behavior key.
If you only turn one, the autism diagnosis just doesn't launch.
Which brings us right to a major diagnostic pitfall.
And this is one that misleads a lot of people in the real world.
Let's say a person has those persistent deficits in social communication.
They genuinely struggle with social cues and the nuance of language.
So they hold that first key.
But their brain doesn't have that need for rigid routine.
They don't have restricted repetitive behaviors or intense sensory fixations.
Wait, so if a child just doesn't understand social nuance or takes everything
literally, but they don't, you know, line up their toys, flap their hands or melt
down when a routine changes, they are not autistic.
Under current clinical guidelines?
No, they would likely be diagnosed with social communication disorder.
It's a completely distinct condition.
The restricted and repetitive piece is the absolute dividing line.
It is the tipping point between the two diagnoses.
That feels like such a stark boundary for something that's literally called a
spectrum.
It is stark, yeah.
But it defines the treatment trajectory, which is why it exists.
If a child has autism, early intensive behavioral interventions are designed to
address both the social deficits and help manage the sensory overwhelm
deriving those repetitive behaviors.
Gotcha.
But if they only have social communication disorder, the therapy focuses
almost exclusively on speech and pragmatic language skills.
The diagnosis basically dictates the entire roadmap.
Okay, so autism is defined by having a very specific combination of
behaviors, but what happens when the behaviors themselves are common everyday
things like getting distracted or being energetic, but they cross a
threshold into a disorder.
Then we are talking about how the brain regulates itself across different
environments, which naturally leads us to attention deficit hyperactivity
disorder or ADHD.
Right.
With ADHD, the core symptoms are categorized as inattention, hyperactivity,
impulsivity, or a combination.
And I think we all generally know what that looks like on the surface.
Sure.
But the diagnostic rules here are entirely about context.
There are two strict rules.
Several symptoms must be present before the age is 12, and they absolutely
must show up in two or more settings, like home and school.
Exactly.
Not just one place.
That's the primary filter.
I have to push back on this a bit though, because it feels, I don't
know, incredibly dismissive of a child's lived experience.
How so?
Well, if a kid is completely failing math because they cannot pay
attention, why does it matter if they're perfectly fine at home playing
video games or, you know, what if a teenager's life falls apart at age
15 and they suddenly can't focus on anything?
Why rule them out just because of their age or their location?
That's a really common concern, but it's because we have to separate
a neurological baseline from an environmental reaction.
It's actually one of the most critical distinctions a clinician has to make.
Okay, explain that.
Let's look at the teenager first.
If a 15-year-old suddenly develops severe inattention out of nowhere, we
need to be looking at trauma or depression, maybe a massive life
transition, or even substance use.
Ah, I see.
A primary neurodevelopmental disorder doesn't just magically
appear in high school, the wiring was there from the beginning.
That's why the age 12 cutoff exists.
Okay, that makes total sense for the age limit.
What about the settings though?
Well, think about the child who only struggles in one specific classroom.
If they are hyperactive and unable to focus in math class, but completely
regulated at home, at soccer practice, and in art class, the problem
is likely the math class.
Oh, situational.
Exactly.
Maybe they're being bullied by someone in that room.
Maybe the teacher's style is deeply incompatible with them, or maybe
they have a specific learning issue with numbers.
That is an acute stress reaction to an environment.
Oh, wow.
So if it's only happening in one place, the brain is reacting to the place,
not a disorder of the brain itself.
Precisely.
ADHD is a fundamental difference in how the brain's executive function works.
If the brain is truly wired that way, those executive function struggles
are going to travel with the child.
Everywhere they go.
Right.
They'll show up at the dinner table, the grocery store, and at the math desk.
The two setting rule proves it's an internal neurological condition, not
just an external environmental reaction.
That completely flips how I view the diagnosis.
It's not this rigid bureaucracy.
It's a protective filter to make sure we aren't, you know, medicating a kid
who just needs a different environment.
Yeah, that's the whole point.
And speaking of medication, that brings up another fascinating mechanism.
Let's hear it.
The first line treatment for school-aged children with ADHD usually
pairs behavioral intervention with stimulant medication, things like
methylphenidate or amphetamines.
Which, I mean, that always sounds so paradoxical to people.
Why on earth would you give a hyperactive kid a stimulant?
Because of what we are actually stimulating.
ADHD isn't just an excess of energy.
It's often a deficit in the neurotransmitters Dokamine and
norepinephrine in the brain's prefrontal cortex.
Okay.
And that's the area responsible for executive function.
It's basically the brain's brakes.
The stimulant wakes up the brakes.
It gives the brain the chemical fuel it needs to regulate
attention and control those impulses.
So you aren't stimulating the child to be more energetic.
You're stimulating the child's ability to pump the brakes.
That's the core of it.
Yeah, that's a great visual.
So we've moved from the combination of behaviors and
autism to the brain's executive brakes in ADHD.
Now let's look at what happens when the brain's actual
processing power is impacted.
Right.
We're moving into intellectual and learning disabilities.
This is a crucial shift.
We're moving away from attention and behavior and
directly into cognition and the acquisition of skills.
Let's start with intellectual disability.
So the criteria here required deficits in both intellectual
functioning and adaptive functioning.
And again, this has to start during the
developmental period.
Yes, that's key.
And reading through the clinical history, there's a
really profound modern shift here.
Historically, society relied almost entirely on an IQ
number.
Right.
Unfortunately, yes.
But modern diagnostics have moved away from that.
Severity is now set by adaptive functioning, not
just an IQ score.
It's a much more humane and frankly accurate way to
understand human capability.
Based on the notes, the best way I can visualize
this is thinking about a car.
Okay.
I like car analogies.
Think of an IQ score like the theoretical horsepower of
an engine hooked up to a diagnostic machine in a
garage.
It tells you exactly how much raw processing power
is there.
Right.
But adaptive functioning, that's how well the car
actually navigates rush hour traffic.
Let's take that analogy a step further.
You can have a high theoretical horsepower, but
if you don't know how to merge lanes or read a
stop sign, or if you completely panic when
someone hawks at you, you can't drive to the
grocery store.
Exactly.
Adaptive functioning is exactly that.
Can a person manage their personal care?
Can they communicate their daily needs?
Can they navigate their community safely?
So a person could have a lower IQ score, but if
they developed incredible adaptive skills, like if
they know how to navigate their specific daily
traffic, their actual severity of impairment
might be quite low.
Exactly.
The impact on daily independent life is the
true measure of the condition.
The modern clinical field cares about the
traffic, not just the engine.
Now let's contrast that global engine issue
with a specific learning disorder.
This involves persistent difficulty with highly
specific skills like reading, written
expression or math, dyslexia, dyscalculia,
conditions like that.
And here is where the diagnostic boundary is
incredibly fine.
For a specific learning disorder, the academic
skill must be well below what is expected for
the person's age.
But there are two massive qualifiers that
prevent this diagnosis from being over-applied.
Ah, yes, the despite and the because.
Right.
First, the difficulties must persist despite
targeted help.
Meaning you can't diagnose a kid with a learning
disorder just because they had, say, a terrible
teacher for two years or missed a lot of
school due to illness.
Correct.
The school has to have noticed the struggle,
provided extra tutoring or special instruction,
and the child is still significantly struggling
to decode words or understand numbers.
It has to resist intervention.
Yes.
It proves the issue isn't a lack of educational
opportunity.
It's an actual neurological roadblock.
And the second qualifier.
It cannot be explained by something else.
The reading struggle can't be because the child
needs glasses and no one noticed.
It can't be because of hearing loss.
And crucially, it cannot be explained by an
intellectual disability.
So going back to the car analogy, an
intellectual disability is an issue with the
overall engine.
A specific learning disorder is like the engine
is running perfectly.
The steering is great.
The driver is navigating traffic flawlessly.
But the radio absolutely refuses to pick up FM
signals.
Yes, perfect.
It is an isolated processing block.
The brain is functioning beautifully in almost
every area.
But there is a specific localized glitch in the
neural pathway that translates visual symbols
into sound or processes numerical quantities.
It's just fascinating how localized the brain
can be.
Yeah.
But you know, so far, everything we've talked
about is internal.
Cognitive hurdles, social processing, attention
spans, reading delays.
Right.
All very internal.
The final category in our exploration brings the
developmental timeline out into the physical
world.
We're talking about the heihetic disorders,
specifically Tourette's.
Yeah.
The diagnostic recipe for Tourette's is
incredibly strict.
A person must have multiple motor ticks plus at
least one vocal tick.
At least one, yes.
And the timeline is key.
They must be present for more than a year with
the onset before age 18.
And we really need to understand the mechanism
of a tick here because it's often
misrepresented as just a random out of nowhere
spasm.
Neurologically, it's usually preceded by
something called a promontory urge.
A promontory urge.
What does that actually feel like?
Think about the feeling you get right before
you sneeze or the intense building itch of
a mosquito bite.
Oh, that terrible anticipation.
Right.
There is a localized physical tension that
builds up in the body.
And the tick, the motor movement or the
vocalization is the release of that tension.
The brain is sending an overwhelming signal
saying, you know, you must do this to find
relief.
That sounds absolutely exhausting, like
fighting a sneeze all day long.
It is.
And it clarifies why the diagnostic boundary is
drawn where it is.
If someone only has motor ticks, like maybe
they constantly blink or shrug their shoulders,
but they never have a vocal tick.
They don't get the Tourette's diagnosis.
I do not.
They would likely be diagnosed with a
persistent motor tick disorder.
Tourette's strictly requires the combination of
both motor and vocal expressions over that
one year period.
I'm really curious about the intervention
strategy here because it seems to completely
flip the script from what we discussed with
ADHD.
It does in a major way.
With ADHD, the clinical standard for kids is
to introduce a chemical stimulant fairly
quickly to help the brain regulate.
But with Tourette's, which is an involuntary
physically jarring condition, the medical
consensus leans heavily away from
medication as a first step.
It's a profound shift in medical philosophy.
Medication for ticks is generally reserved
only for severe cases where the ticks are
causing pain or severe social impairment.
So what's the alternative?
The first line defense is psychoeducation
and a highly specialized therapy.
The comprehensive behavioral intervention for
ticks or CBIT.
Yes, CBIT.
Because cedics are preceded by that
promontory urge, that itch we talked about,
CBIT trains the person to become hyper
aware of that exact physical sensation
right before it happens.
Okay.
Once they can identify the urge building,
they are taught to perform a competing
physical behavior.
Wait, how does a competing behavior work?
Well, if the urge is telling your brain
that you need to violently jerk your head
back, the competing response might be to
gently tense your neck muscles and push
your chin down slightly.
Oh, I see.
You perform a subtle, socially acceptable
movement that uses the exact same muscle
groups, making the actual tick physically
impossible to execute at the same time.
Wow.
So you're basically giving the brain an
alternative release valve for the tension.
You are.
You're retraining the physical response to
the neurological urge.
It doesn't cure the underlying neurology,
but it gives agency back to the individual.
It allows them to manage the physical
manifestation before anyone starts altering
their brain chemistry with pharmaceuticals.
That is incredibly empowering.
It really highlights how much of modern
diagnosis is about finding the right tool
for the right localized issue.
It's about precision in a very
imprecise field.
Well, we have covered a massive amount
of ground today, and I want to make sure
we lock these boundaries in for you.
Let's recap.
We started with autism, where the
diagnostic key isn't just a lack of
social fluidity, but the absolute
necessity of restricted, repetitive
behaviors, you know, the brain's way
of anchoring itself in a chaotic,
sensory world.
And without those repetitive
behaviors, you are looking at social
communication disorder.
Right.
Then we looked at ADHD where the
diagnosis acts as a filter.
Symptoms must cross multiple environments
and appear before age 12 to prove
it's a true neurological baseline,
a deficit in the brain's executive
breaks, and not just a child reacting
to a stressful environment.
From there, we shifted to cognition
with intellectual disability, where
the modern clinical world prioritizes
adaptive functioning.
How well you navigate the traffic of
daily life over the raw engine
horsepower of an IQ score, which is
distinctly different from a specific
learning disorder, where the engine
and the traffic are fine, but an
isolated neural pathway struggles
with a specific skill, persisting
despite targeted educational support.
And finally, the physical realm of
Tourette's, requiring the strict
combination of multiple motor ticks
and at least one vocal tick, driven
by that internal promontory urge
and managed first through behavioral
retraining rather than medication.
It really is a masterclass in how
carefully these lines have to be
drawn. If you get the boundary
wrong, you apply the wrong treatment
and you completely misunderstand
the fundamental nature of what the
person is experiencing.
And that actually leads to a thought
that I think changes how you view
everyone around you.
No.
We've spent this entire time
talking about these incredibly
specific strict childhood criteria.
Timelines, multiple settings,
precise behavioral combinations.
But these diagnostic boundaries
in their current refined forms
are relatively modern.
Oh, man, I see where you're going
with this.
Think about the generations of adults
walking around today, people who are
in their 40s, 50s or 70s.
How many of them grew up with these
overlapping traits, but because they
lived before these precise lines
were drawn, they were completely
misunderstood.
They were just, you know, the day
dreamers of the lazy kid or the
weird uncle.
Exactly.
They were navigating this
incredibly murky neurological
landscape completely without a map.
They didn't have a lack of
willpower. They had a brain that
lacked dopamine in its frontal
lobe.
Yeah, they weren't willfully
stubborn. Their sensory system was
overwhelmed and needed routine.
The diagnostic X-ray machine might
be fuzzy, but it's terrifying
to think about how many people
never even got to step into the
clinic.
That reframes everything.
It's not just about categorizing
conditions, it's about validating
a person's reality.
Well, thank you for walking
through this diagnostic maze with
me. And if you've ever wondered why
someone's brain works the way it
does, hopefully this deep dive gives
you a new lens to view them
through. Keep questioning, keep
exploring, and we'll catch you on
the next deep dive.